déjà entendu parler du fameux à régime
dukan atkins montignac ou encore le
régime dissocié il existe une multitude
de méthodes destinées à la perte de
poids si certaines s'avèrent bénéfiques
et efficaces d'autres demandent plus
d'efforts et ont tendance à provoquer le
fameux effet yoyo que l'on connaît bien
mais comment notre corps réguler t-il
notre poids quel rôle le cerveau joue
t-il aussi et surtout dans ce mécanisme
sommes-nous égaux face aux aux calories
on en parle avec vous julia siggers
bonjour suler bonjour elisabeth on
évoque avec vous cette cette question
avec cette première question comment
notre organisme assure-t-il la fameuse
régulation du poids alors ce qui est
important c'est que l'organisme cherche
en permanence un équilibre il va le
faire grâce à plein de mécanismes de
régulation et de contrôle et il en va de
même pour le poids et le centre de
régulation pondérale se trouve dans le
cerveau d'un autre hypothalamus s'il
arrive à recevoir toutes les
informations provenant du corps par
rapport au stock d'énergie qui sont
encore disponibles mais aussi par
rapport aux besoins de notre corps est
en fait ce qui est intéressant là dedans
c'est que notre corps nous parle de
façon constante mais qu'on ne sait pas
l'écouté et on ne sait pas comprendre ce
qu'il nous dit alors je vous donne des
exemples de la manière dont notre corps
aidez nous à comprendre voilà comment
notre corps nous parle au quotidien et
bien écoutez avec la fin tout simplement
il notre corps nous dit je n'ai pas
assez d'énergie pour pouvoir fonctionner
j'ai besoin de plus de nutriments avec
les envies qui sont spécifiques que l'on
retrouve souvent chez les femmes
enceintes ça peut nous indiquer une
carence une envie par exemple
irrépressible de jus d'orange ça peut
être par exemple une carence en vitamine
c après vous avez le rassasiement là où
vous avez l'impression d'avoir vraiment
assez mangé bien là vous avez déjà trop
manger et parce qu'en fait le but c'est
plutôt d'arriver à ce que l'on appelle
la satiété c'est très différent c'est un
état de non feint que l'on retrouve
plutôt entre les repas là où votre corps
vous dit j'ai exactement ce qu'il me
faut puisque quand vous avez trop mangé
bien là votre corps va devoir passer
plus de temps plus d'énergie à
décomposer les aliments et à digérer
tout cela est la société ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est ça qui va
vous empêcher de grignoter entre les
repas et donc de prendre du poids c'est
à ce moment là que votre corps va
libérer une hormone que l'on appelle la
ligue tine et on pense d'ailleurs que
les personnes qui ont des troubles du
comportement alimentaire ont du mal on
n'arrive pas à se connecter avec cette
hormone l'a donc le but c'est vraiment
d'essayer des coûts et son corps c'est
ce qu'on appelle l' approche
comportementale de prendre en
considération que le fait de manger
c'est aussi quelque chose de très
émotionnel est arrivé à s'arrêter à
temps surtout alors vous entendre ça a
l'air extrêmement simple écouter son
corps peux vous dire que ça ne marche
pas à tous les coups dans les faits on
est effectivement pas tous à notre poids
optimal de santé alors sommes-nous c'est
une vraie question qui se pose tous
égaux face à la régulation du poids
alors c'est pas qu'on ait pas égaux
c'est qu'on est tous très différents on
n'a pas tous le même poids d'origine ou
encore une fois le corps va constamment
essayé de revenir à cet équilibre donc
on a un tout tout ce qu'on appelle un
poil naturel de départ ça se voit bien
que la naissance de tout fait exactement
absolument ensuite on n'a pas les mêmes
types de métabolisme vous savez des
métabolismes landais métabolisme plus
rapide donc les métabolismes rapide pour
avoir besoin d'une quantité de
nourriture plus important pour justement
maintenir les fonctions vitales ils vont
digérer plus facilement ils vont perdre
du poids plus facilement et ils vont
avoir un transit plus rapides également
à linverse les métabolismes langues
elles ont plus de mal à perdre du poids
il sont des transits plus plu lancée
terre en général aussi des vues des
personnes plus frileuses et elles vont
avoir besoin de moins de nourriture en
sachant aussi que les métabolismes il
faut le savoir évolué tout au long de la
vie donc ça c'est très important et
aussi qu'il y à un facteur génétique qui
est très important dans tout cela
également oui pareil pour vip c'est plus
c'est compliqué il paraît faux pas le
savoir c'est pour ça que vous avez un
certain certain nombre de régimes qui se
base sur votre groupe sanguin possible
cible alors là vous faites référence est
assez intéressant c'est une hypothèse en
fait qui a été lancé par james adamo qui
est un naturopathe américain et qui
considère qu'en fait le régime l'a en
tout cas se base sur l'idée que
dépendamment de votre groupe sanguin
votre groupe sanguin va en fait avoir
une composition chimique particulière et
bien elle va réagir avec la nourriture
la composition chimique dans la
nourriture d'une certaine manière il ya
il y a des des liens ou qui ne peuvent
pas se faire qu ils sont tout simplement
incompatible vous savez les groupes
souvenir ce soir des groupes c'est
passionnant voilà donc vous le savez les
groupes sanguins se sont développées
tout au long des millénaires avec le
groupe eau par exemple je suis chasseur
cueilleur vous êtes chasseur cueilleur
et bien si vous êtes chasseur cueilleur
on vous pour qu'on préconise d'éviter
les produits serré et céréalier est
plutôt une consommation de protéines
animales le groupe sanguin à sas et
diversifier un peu plus tard on la
retrouve et au début de l'agriculture là
on va prôner plutôt une aliments station
qui va être végétarienne ensuite les
groupes b et ab là ce sont au moment des
peuples plus nomade donc on va avoir une
variété d'aliments qui sont plus
importants ce qui est important
aujourd'hui c'est de comprendre que de
plus en plus il faut faire on l'a dit
tout à l'heure il y à de nombreux
facteurs à prendre en considération est
évidemment mais que cette fonction
comportementale aussi une fois de plus
essayez d'écouter son corps de connaître
son métabolisme de connaître son poids
idéal et encore ce conseil peut être le
plus important c'est vraiment d'aller
consulter quelqu'un une diététicienne
nutritionniste qui peut vraiment vous
aider parce que si on choisit pas le bon
le bon régime eh bien on peut dérégler
complètement son corps et on peut même
ralentir son métabolisme encore plus on
n'a pas une petite réaction à entendre
tout de suite non c'est déjà terminé
mais voilà c'est terminé oui merci
julien vous voyez en leur demandant on
n'avait pas on n'avait pas atteint la
fameuse satiété merci vocaux julia
skieurs c'était le billet science du